[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up prof
hello walter hi martin what's with this
new dress code of yours man i thought
i'd become mustardy so i can start
rolling up my sleeves
get ready get ready i think there's a
shaking coming
that's true
so before we get to the shaking let's
ask the lord to bless this discussion
hi heavenly father thank you for
bringing us again together
lord
important things have to be discussed
and we ask that you bless our minds and
also enlighten us
in the way that you want the discussion
to go we ask this in jesus name amen
amen
you know what's interesting to me
is the way in which
these discussions
develop you know i'm sure some people
have the notion that we sit like book
worms and prepare word for word what we
are going to say
when
mostly we haven't got a clue
that's what we're going to say
and we just
go and pray and say lord
there there's so much
what do you
what do you do how do you filter these
things out and what is essential for the
time in which we are living
and the war is definitely heating up
and some of it is
of a nature
that you wouldn't expect right
so let's try and be kind and
nevertheless
be straightforward when it comes to
these things yes you see the the the
we're not we're not doing the cutting
the word must do the cutting the truth
must do that's the thing so if we bring
out the word
and this what's said in the spirit of
prophecy
it's not to be vengeful no
it's to try and bring it to the fore
like you've mentioned in this the
episodes before to bring out a
discussion yes now today we have two
books here as usual and normally my
bible is also lying here
but today i brought the testimonies
for the church and i've been reading
this one again i don't know for the
harmonious time
but it gets to be a very interesting
situation
and
you know we're talking about many issues
here one of the things that i read about
in here was about the rebellion of korra
and how serious that was and how
disillusioned
they were korra dayton and byram yeah
they didn't even know that they were on
the wrong side of the issue
and even after god's retributive action
where they were swallowed up
the people were still convinced that
this was a sinister plot by moses to get
rid of them yeah
although logically how could he open up
the ground and swallow them up right
yeah
and it was only through the intercession
of moses that a tremendous plague was
stayed
that just shows you how strong
the influence of misinformation can be
yeah
now which
testimonies to the church do you have
there
this one over here is testimonies to the
church volume
3. what is interesting to me
is that
she has a few interesting things to say
about
reproof
for the church
and what the problem was with these
people for example
why they were so
upset
about what had happened to
korra and company
she states that the people were totally
confused on the issue
their minds had been
thoroughly poisoned with disaffection
and they had the matter fixed beyond the
question in their minds that moses and
aaron were wicked men
so it's quite easy to
see how people can think that those that
stand for truth and rebuke sin are
actually the wicked ones right it is
because most of the time
they that do it are not popular with
what's going on
in the world correct
and that they were responsible for the
death of kora dathan and the byram who
they thought
who would have been the saviors of the
hebrews by bringing in a better order of
things
where praise would take place of reproof
isn't that interesting very interesting
and peace the place of anxiety
and conflict and they accused them they
said ye have killed the people of the
lord
now
these are stories written for us and for
the time that we are living in
and those that say
things such as korra and byram
and those said
should be very very careful how they
approach these things
she says here on page 360 god would have
his people disciplined
and brought into harmony of action
that they may see eye to eye
and be of the same mind and of the same
judgment
uh if you look at the church today that
is impossible right
in order to bring about this state of
things there is much to be done the
carnal heart must be subdued and
transformed god has
designs
that there shall ever be a living
testimony
in the church
and then at the end of page 361 she says
god designs that his people shall be a
unit
and they shall see eye to eye and be of
the same mind and of the same judgment
with every wind of doctrine blowing in
the church today
are we of the same mind
no
this cannot be accomplished without a
clear pointed living
testimony
in the church
the prayer of christ was that his
disciples might be one
as he was one with the father
and then she quotes the bible text where
jesus
says
that particular prayer now martin
i have said from the beginning and i'm
sure that you agree
that the only way
in which we can become one in mind and
purpose
is if we base our theology and our
thinking on the same criteria that's it
your
basis your anchor should be the same and
therefore
the bible
and the spirit of prophecy
must become
the basis anything that deviates from it
anything that twists it distorts it
changes its direction
sets the train on another spore
that's it
anything of that nature will lead to
disharmony
only as we combine
to the law and to the testimony can we
become one
and it's also important that the part
that says to the law has to come from
the right law
it cannot be based on spurious
manuscripts
that is true you know we've had many of
these discussions and i mean the issue
of bible translations
is a major headache for many people now
in the modern translations
it is impossible
to defend some of our doctrines and even
some of the spirit of prophecy
statements so that's what makes it so
difficult correct and if you take the
time frames
let's say of
the septuagint
they differ substantially from the
masoretic text
now
which one are you going to rely on
to the law and through the testimony so
the spirit of prophecy is in harmony
with the masoretic text but it is
definitely what time frames are cons
where time frames are concerned not in
harmony with the septuagint right
so i don't know why this is such a huge
issue
because it's really not rocket science
but let's not go in that direction
because this gets many feathers right
rightfully let's look at some of the
other very important issues to the law
and to the testimony
nothing against the truth
but for the truth
we want to continue that study yeah and
we'll mingle it with again some of the
experiences
that we have had and that i've had and
see where we can
find some
substance to base our faith on
the straight testimony called forth by
the council of the true witness to the
laodiceans
is something that is not very popular no
no
as we read quora's company said
all the people are holy
don't make a distinction between those
that do this and don't do that right
we're all holy we're all god's chosen
people
yes god chose the whole world yeah but
that doesn't mean that the whole world
accepts him right no there's certain
criteria you have to adhere to
now the pope
and this is a fascinating
statement that he made in 2019 already
the pope says christians should never
seek to convert unbelievers
anyone
who proselytizes
is not a disciple of jesus it's an
amazing statement go into all the world
and preach the gospel and make disciples
this statement is directly opposed to
that
it's amazing
in a dialogue with catholic high school
students in rome this weekend pope
francis responded to a question about
how to deal with atheists
and people of other faiths by saying
that christians should never proselytize
and any who do are not true christians
that's incredible right
notable remarks illustrating the pub's
view on evangelism including speaking of
having jewish and muslim friends
we are all the same
all children of god
correct
everybody on this
whole earth
is a child of god
but not everybody wants to be a child of
god
true right
it didn't occur to me and it doesn't
have to be like saying to a boy or a
girl you are jewish you are a muslim
come be converted we are not in the
times of the crusades
in front of an unbeliever the last thing
i have to do is to try to convince him
never
but listen never never bring the gospel
by
proselytizing
if someone says they are a disciple of
jesus and comes to you with proselytism
they are not a disciple of jesus the
church does not grow by proselytism
last year pope francis told a grieving
boy that his father was in heaven
despite the fact that he was an atheist
because he had his children baptized
it's really an amazing statement this
goes directly against jesus's
instruction yeah
now i've had quite a number of
experiences that i might want to share
in this regard
within our own church
many many years ago
i was
a speaker at the camp meeting
and there was another
speaker a prominent american preacher
who was the other speaker
and as often the case i find myself in
these terrible situations
i'm always in trouble
when my message was the exact opposite
of his message
what do you do in a case like that and
you ask yourself why lord
but you know if i think back in in
history
always
whenever there was a major event that
was to take place
twin messages went into the world yeah
right
one based on error
one based on truth sometimes twin
messages both based on error
but god
is fair and he always allows a choice so
in 1844
the message went out from charles darwin
we are the product of evolution
in 1844
a message went out to the world worship
god and give him the glory that's it
for the hour of his judgment has come
worship him who made
the opposite of the evolution two
messages
which one is uh popular in the world
the one that says we come from
a bottle of slime
absolutely so you have these twin
messages there are many many examples
and i don't want to run ahead of myself
but in some future
what's ups we will discuss some very
interesting twin messages
that have gone out into the world
and the world embraces
on a regular basis that which is not
biblical yeah but we'll come to that
at a later point
so this man
at this camp meeting he was preaching
about
the view that we have to reach the whole
world with the gospel message and this
gospel will be preached in the whole
world right and then the end will come
and his basic understanding was
that god winks at the time of ignorance
and therefore it is presumption to
assume
that you have to reach a nation let's
say
china
with the gospel
if you don't preach to them
his view was that they're all saved
because they don't have to make a choice
then whereas if you do preach to them
they might make the wrong choice and be
lost
so you will be responsible
for
their demise that was his basic message
so stop this nonsense of preaching
to the world just leave them
that's exactly what the pope is saying
here
exactly the same
and i was sweating bullets
when i was listening to this
and there were literally thousands of
people
at the camp meeting
thousands i i don't want to give the
figures but it was thousands it was a
big camp meeting
and i had to follow that act
i was the next preacher for the next
sermon
and i thought to myself what am i going
to do what am i going to say how am i
going to
address this issue
or am i just going to leave it and let
the people decide for themselves
and i got onto the pulpit and before i
could stop myself
it just popped out
go ye into all the world and preach the
gospel
pandemonium
so i had an enemy
for life
at the many years later or not so many
years later a few years later
i was in the united states
and i was going to preach to
his church
and
i wasn't going to preach to the adults i
was going to preach to the youth
and that was an amazing experience
because it was obvious that they
they weren't very keen
on having me there but somehow i'd been
invited how does that happen
you can do nothing against the truth but
for the truth somehow i ended up at this
youth church
and the pastor arrived on the stage with
his shirt unbuttoned to here with an
electric guitar around his neck
and an earring in his ear
which is very strange right
and
he basically
said that
i was one of the speakers
but i wasn't going to get more than 10
minutes oh
this seems to be a trend 10 minutes is a
trend yes and a
band that goes pre previous to you
correct
so there was there was a lot of
what should we call it modern so we call
it music
going on
and a lot of uh
gesticulation
and eventually i did get my ten minutes
and
i told my story but i sometimes have a
streak in me
that god is still working on
so i told my story in such a fashion
that
i brought it to a short crescendo
but didn't give the outcome
and said sorry my time's up i can't tell
you what happened
and the whole audience said no no no you
must carry on and i said no you your
pastor said there's no way that i can
carry on i have 10 minutes and that's it
bottom line i i spoke for one and a half
hours
so sometimes these things happen
the doors are open and sometimes the
doors are closed
and
he also had a very interesting sermon
this is now the main preacher
he had a very interesting sermon
uh
also about
well he was talking about a king with
made decrees etc
and basically
it was very similar to some of the
sermons that i heard you don't prune a
tree
you must allow the tree to grow just as
it wants to
pruning is a very painful experience and
that's exactly
what the people were saying
but that's exactly what the bible tells
you to do yeah and what the people were
saying about korra that he was he wasn't
going to prune the tree it was going to
be a better situation moses was a tree
pruner he must stop this nonsense don't
tell us what to do the whole
congregation is holy right
so
this kind of thinking
is not only
in the papacy
this kind of thinking of course is
necessary for the papacy
yes absolutely right because he doesn't
want another reformation
where he loses a large proportion of his
church and he once
we've spoken about it before that
the papacy basket
can catch all the fish yes it is
perfectly suited to save those that are
in their sins
and those that want to be saved by their
works
so it can embrace a large well most of
the human society
this kind of thinking
is an exceedingly dangerous
way of thinking
and it should have no place
within seventh-day adventism what do you
do with the verse that says their blood
be on your head if you don't tell them
exactly
and
if you go to the stories of the bible
let's just go there and then we'll tell
some
more serious stories of what can happen
to us
now
when we go to the bible and we see what
happened there
and we go to what happened to the
disciples and we read all about it in
the book of acts how often
they were arrested for speaking in the
name of jesus right which the pope just
said you should never
you shouldn't do that right
you go to acts chapter 4 and as they
spoke unto the people the priests and
the captains of the temple and the
sadducees came upon them
being grieved that they taught the
people and preached through jesus the
resurrection from the dead in other
words they preached a doctrine
which wasn't a very comfortable doctrine
it's also not a very comfortable
doctrine for the papacy because the dead
are all happily either in heaven or in
purgatory or damned in hell already
right
and they laid hands on them and put them
in hold until the next day for it was
now even tied how being many of them
which had heard the word believe
and the number of the men was about
5 000.
so that was very successful preaching
right
i don't think that the pope would have
been happy he would have been right at
the spearhead of that crowd of priests
and captains
and sadducees that came to arrest these
people right yeah yeah and it's always
it's uh
the small theological committee that
came out and took care of these guys
into the
laid hands on them
absolutely and it came to pass on the
morrow that the rulers and elders and
scribes and anas the high priest and
caiaphas and john and alexander and as
many as were
of the kindred of the high priest were
gathered together at jerusalem i find it
interesting that some of these names
are mentioned
and they're not mentioned in a positive
light right
and when they had sat them in the midst
they asked by what power or what name
have ye done this because they had
healed a man right in the name of jesus
then peter filled with the holy ghost
said unto them ye rulers of the people
and elders of israel
if we this day be examined for the good
deed done to the impotent man
by what means is he made whole
be it known unto you all
and to all the people of israel that by
the name of jesus christ of nazareth
whom ye crucified whom god raised from
the dead even by him does this man stand
here before you
whole they were very bold yeah
and they preached jesus
and beholding the man which was healed
standing with them they could say
nothing against it
but when they had commanded them to go
aside out of the council they conferred
amongst
themselves reminds me of these little
huddles
standing in a group discussing how to
deal with this
saying what shall we do to these men for
that indeed a notable miracle has been
done by them is manifest to all them
that dwell in jerusalem
and we cannot deny it
and this is fascinating
in spite of the evidence yes
they will deny it even if they say we
cannot deny it they still go ahead and
deny they still go ahead with it
but that it spread no further
amongst the people let us straightly
threaten them
that they speak henceforth to no man in
this name
and they called them and commanded them
not to speak at all nor teach in the
name of jesus
but peter and john answered and said
unto them whether it be right in the
sight of god to hearken unto you more
than unto god judge ye
for we cannot but speak the things which
we have seen and heard and that is what
you must say
to all
who have like sentiments
it's as plain as that
here we stand we can do no other we will
just have to do it
so martin that wasn't an isolated case
because in acts 5
it's like pushing the reset button and
you go back to the same verse right
so then
the high priest rose up and all they
that were with them which is the sect of
the sadducees which were filled with
indignation
i think indignation is going to be the
name of the game right
and laid their hands on the apostles and
put them into common prison
but the angel of the lord by night
opened the prison dawn brought them
forth and said go stand and speak
in the temple to the people all the
words of this life
go preach the gospel
which is salvation in jesus christ
go
proselytize absolutely go and preach
so what do we do with
china
what do we do with confucianism what do
we do with islam what do we do with
anyone that the pope embraces and says
leave them exactly as they are
we have to go and preach
an angel
came and opened the prison
this must have driven them crazy
then came one and told them saying
behold
the men who ye put in prison are
standing in the temple and teaching the
people
then went the captain with the officers
and brought them without violence for
they feared the people lest they should
have been stoned and when they had
brought them they set them before the
council and the high priest asked them
saying
did not we straightly command you that
you should not teach in this name
and behold you have filled jerusalem
with your doctrine and intent to bring
this man's blood upon us
we told you to stop yeah
don't say that
did they stop
they couldn't they got an
uh they're marching orders from god an
angel released them from prison and said
go
then peter and the other apostles
answered and said we ought to obey god
rather than men and this is the issue
martin
this is not going to stop
so we are going to face this more and
more
when they heard that they were cut to
their hearts and took counsel to slay
them so in other words if you cannot
suppress it
eventually you will
resort to violence that's it right
it first comes to being going personal
and then to violence eventually
then stood there up one in the council a
pharisee named khamalil a doctor of the
law
and he had a reputation amongst all the
people and commanded to put the apostles
forth the little space just take them
outside
and said unto them you men of israel
take here to yourselves what you intend
to do as touching these men
and now i say unto you refrain from
these men and let them alone
for if this council or this world be of
men
it will come to naught
the very good advice that
this is very sound advice so all these
people
that constantly scream about what is
being said
if it is not from god it will come to
naught yeah
why do they want to follow the way
of the sanhedrin and put these people in
jail and command them to be silent
when they have a commission sometimes
which they feel comes from god directly
to preach it
but even be of god you cannot overthrow
it lest happily you be found even to
fight against god
and to him their greed and when they had
called the apostles and beaten them
isn't that interesting
i beat them
they commanded that they should not
speak in the name of jesus and let them
go and they departed from the prison of
the council rejoicing that they were
counted worthy to suffer shame for his
name
and daily in the temple and every house
they ceased not to teach and preach
jesus christ did it work no
no it didn't work
so my advice to all of these people
that want to silence everyone
even if he's speaking
contrary to the truth
do you want to put him in jail do you
want to beat him do you want to stop him
if it is not from god
it will come to naught
testimony and the law
but if it is according to the bible and
the testimony
they are fighting against god
and no matter how much they beat
and know how much they censure
it won't help because god's message
cannot
be
suppressed you can do nothing against
the truth
only for the truth
their actions
did it suppress the gospel or further
the gospel the gospel why don't they
learn
is this been history
middle ages
let's take another example acts chapter
12 verse 6 and when herod
who had brought him forth the same night
peter was sleeping between two soldiers
bound with chains
and the keepers before the door kept the
prison they made sure they won't go
preaching again right so this is the
third time already
and behold the angel of the lord came
upon him and a light shined in the
prison
and he smote peter on the side and
raised him up saying arise up quickly
and his chains fell off from his hands
when peter was come to himself he said
now i know of a surety
that the lord has sent his angel and has
delivered me out of the hand of herod
and from the
expectation of the people of the jews
now it was church and stayed together
yeah
right
because it says they has delivered me
out of the hand of herod and from all
the expectation
of the people of the jews so the
threatenings first came from inside and
later the arm of the state was added
they get that part where they have to
enforce it
correct now as soon as it was day there
was no small stir amongst the soldiers
what was become of peter and when herod
had sought for him and found him not he
examined the keepers and commanded that
they should be put to death and he went
down from judea to caesarea and there
about can you do anything against the
truth no
no did this make the truth even more
prominent yes it spread like wildfire
let's take an example from the old
testament
jeremiah i love the story of jeremiah do
you know martin that the book of
jeremiah
is a type of the three angels messages
definitely you can find all three angels
messages
get out of babylon flee from babylon
right and the way for your lives and the
way he's treated is also the way people
that preach the three angels messi just
get treated it's a perfect time
and then of course he also bemoans the
fact that they didn't keep the sabbath
so even the third angel's message is in
there
now
we read in chapter 32
for then the king of babylon army
besieged jerusalem and jeremiah the
prophet was shut up in the court of the
prison
which was in the king of judah's house
there poor jeremiah sat in prison
for zedekiah king of judah had shut him
up saying wherefore dost thou prophesy
and say
thus says the lord behold i will give
this city into the hand of the king of
babylon and he shall take it
the king didn't like that message right
so if you don't like the message shut
him up kill the messenger
then jeremiah called baruch
son of neriah
and baruch wrote from the mouth of
jeremiah all the words of the lord which
he had spoken unto him upon a role of a
book
so he wrote out a testimony
and he sent it to the king
and jeremiah commanded baruch saying i
am shut up
i cannot go into the house of the lord
so what even if you shut up the
messenger does it stop the message no
because the message doesn't come from
the messenger he's just the carrier of
it correct it comes from god so off goes
the message never go thou and read
in the role what does written from my
mouth the words of the lord
in the ears of the people in the lord's
house upon the fasting day
and also thou shalt read them in the
ears of all judah that come out of their
cities
it may be they will present their
supplications before the lord and will
return everyone from his evil way
for great is the anger and fury that the
lord has pronounced against this people
did they
unfortunately no no but nevertheless
they had to hear the message right
whether they will hear or whether they
will forebear they had to hear the
message
and they came to pass when yehuda had
read three or four leaves he didn't get
very far
he cut it with a pen knife and cast it
into the fire that was on the hearth
until all the roll was consumed in the
fire that was on the earth
yet they were not afraid nor rent their
garments neither the king nor any of his
servants that heard all of these words
it had no effect on them
but they had to hear exactly
and those words were not only for that
king they were for our time
exactly because it's the type of the
three angels messages
nevertheless
al-natan
and elia
and gamaraya
had made intercession to the king that
he would not burn the role but he would
not hear them were there people that
were faithful definitely
it's like himalayan with peter there's
always someone that says listen
and nevertheless they beat the disciples
right
even after that advice
but the king commanded yaramil the son
of hamelech and saraiah the son of
azrael
and shelimaya the son of abdeal to take
baruch the scribe and jeremiah the
prophet
but the lord hid him
so now the poor messenger was to be
locked up as well right
so the lord hid him
now it's interesting that we drop down
to verse 32 it says then took jeremiah
another role
and gave it to baruch the scribe the son
of neriah
who wrote therein from the mouth of
jeremiah all the words of the book
which joha kim king of judah had burned
in the fire and then these
interesting words
and they were added besides unto them
many like words
love that text
gave a little bit more it gave more
information
you know martin i find in my own life
that this has happened to me many times
as well
when i started preaching on
sacred societies and their role in
prophecy
and everybody said
conspiracy theory
i was also told by the leading powers
in some of the modern sanhedrin councils
that i should cease and desist from
preaching these
things and
when i was told that
i thought to myself you know maybe they
haven't got enough evidence
and so instead of two lectures it turned
out to be 36 lectures which was the
total onslaught series that's how it
developed
the reason why it developed
was because of the opposition
because i thought why don't they see it
let me give more more facts and i i
quoted from all the original sources
yeah
i quoted from
from albert albert pike morales and
dogma you know that one of the leading
brethren came to me and said who's alvid
pike he's not important at all
so i was in the 33 degree freemason
lodge
in washington dc where all the important
decisions are made
and i ended up in the basement remember
and i came into the albert pike room
which was a museum
and
they caught me down there where i
shouldn't be and i said where's the
washroom
and the man shouted at me and said you
are standing on holy ground
and i said what is holy about this
ground
this is the albert
grave pike
whatever
and i thought to myself you know now and
people say this is
it was irrelevant right
so anyway
many a time this is the experience that
god's people have to go through
as another quote we as a people have not
accomplished the work which god has
committed to us we are not ready for the
issue to which the enforcement of the
sunday law will bring us
it is our duty
as we see the signs of approaching peril
to arouse to action
none sit in calm expectation of the evil
comforting themselves with the belief
that this work must go on because
prophecy has foretold it
and that the lord will shelter his
people
we are not doing the will of god if we
sit in quietude doing nothing to
preserve liberty of conscience
when something goes against liberty of
conscience we are compelled
to speak
fervent effectual prayer should be
ascending to heaven that this calamity
may be deferred until we can accomplish
the work which has so long been
neglected
let there be more earnest prayer
and let
us work in harmony with our prayers
we have a commission just like the early
disciples had to go and preach
that's the work what must we preach the
three angels messages right
and if you keep yourself busy with that
you won't be sidetracked
or derailed correct
it is our duty to do all in our power to
avert the threatened danger we should
endeavor to disarm prejudice by placing
ourselves in a proper light before the
people we should bring before them the
real question at issue
thus interposing the most effectual
protest against measures to restrict
liberty of conscience
in other words
the issue must be crystal clear
the choices between the commandments of
god and the commandments of men the
choice is between obeying god and
obeying man
and if the issue is not clearly stated
how can people make a choice they can't
it is not enough to merely profess to
believe the truth all the soldiers of
the cross of christ virtually obligate
themselves to enter the crusade
against the adversary of souls to
condemn wrong and sustain righteousness
but
the message of the true witness reveals
the fact that a terrible deception is
upon our people
which makes it necessary to come to them
with warnings to break their spiritual
slumber and arouse them to decided
action
remember we had a discussion on the true
witness yeah it's the testimony that's
it
i was shown that even this decided
message of the true witness had not
accomplished the design of god
people pay lip service to the testament
but they deny the essence thereof
when it comes to the health message
it is a minority that adheres to the
health message they preach it and
proclaim it but they don't adhere to
themselves
the people slumber on in their sins they
continue to declare themselves rich and
having need of nothing many inquire why
are all these reproofs given
sounds like the people in the days of
core are right
why do the testimonies continually
charge us with backsliding and with
grievous sins
it is a backsliding church that lessens
the distance between itself and rome
that's it that's a reproof
we don't want to hear it
stop this noise
we will not allow you to speak we will
try and get you into prison we will do
whatever we can to silence your voice
right
we love the truth
we are prospering
we are
in no need of these testimonies of
warning and reproof martin this is
exactly
what is happening
in the church
we want to be accepted
we want to be
part of the crowd yeah let's read one
more and then i'll tell you a story
a few persons pass on in a course of
wrong until they become hardened
they may even know that the church is
burdened as aiken knew that israel were
made weak before their enemies because
of his guilt
yet their consciences do not condemn
them
they will not relieve the church by
humbling their proud rebellious hearts
before god and putting away their wrongs
god's displeasure is upon his people
and he will not manifest his power in
the midst of them while sins exist
amongst them and are fostered
by those in responsible positions
those who work in the fear of god to rid
the church of hindrances and to correct
grievous wrongs
that the people of god may see the
necessity of abhoring sin
and may prosper in purity and that the
name of god may be glorified
will ever meet with resisting influences
from the unconsecrated
some years ago
no in fact quite a few years ago
i had a very interesting
experience in my life we'd been through
a very tough time
my wife had had a terrible fall she had
broken her femur
smashed her
her hip
and she was in great suffering
and because the entire hip had been
crushed
everything was tied together with screws
she wasn't allowed to put any weight on
her leg for
for six months and then she had to learn
to walk all over again
and
we were
in south africa
and we thought you know we'd give time
for
recovery
and then we will continue with the work
and i was
here in one of the northern provinces of
south africa
and we wanted to drive back home my wife
was still on crutches she could hardly
walk
and as we drove home someone said to me
you know
i should come to botswana
because they wanted me to do
some sermons there
and
i was with a friend
in fact it was francois
and
i said to him you know i can't go to
botswana now we've got too many problems
my wife is still not well she can't walk
uh i don't want to go to botswana i'm
we're going to go home to recover
so he said okay while you drive back
home i will drive with you until we get
to the place where we go north and you
go south
but before before we got to the place
where
he goes north and i go south
i was confronted with the situation i
was driving along this road
and there was a vehicle in front of me
that was a typical african vehicle
it was held together
with
band-aids
and spider webs
and it was driving along
and i thought
i will have to pass this car
and i still had a caravan on the back
which is like a recreational vehicle
because we were at the camp meeting
and i thought i'll have to pass him but
there was a truck coming from the front
so i was going to wait till the truck
was passed then i could pass this
vehicle which was going very slowly
so it was coming down the hill and the
truck was coming and i started to
accelerate so that when the truck was
passed i would be able to get past him
but as the truck passed him
it created a wind
and this wind was just too much for the
band-aids
so the car in front of me virtually
disintegrated from the wind from the
truck from the truck so the bonnet flew
open the fender flew off
and came hurtling towards us and hit my
car and of course because his bonnet had
been totally wrapped over his windscreen
this guy poor guy couldn't see where he
was going
so he stood
across the road like this and i had
already accelerated to past him when
this truck was passed me
and the truck was driver was unaware of
what was happening behind him
and so i greeted him
with
with much aplomb
and that was the end of my car
so we had to wait until
they towed us in
and i took it to
the next town
to and we found the insurance etc and
the insurance wouldn't allow us to have
the car fixed in that town
it had to be in another town in other
words the vehicle had to be loaded onto
a truck and taken almost a thousand
kilometers to be fixed in another place
and
we were arguing with the insurance
company about this issue
and eventually they said you know
this thing is not going to be sorted out
before a week is passed
so you just better find yourselves a
place to stay for a week
so now what
so
francoise said to me you know what i'm
going north
and you're not going south
and i'm going there for a week
so i ended up in botswana
whether i wanted to or not
so i had plans to go south
but god had plans for me to go north
and broken hip and broken bones
despite we ended up in botswana and we
had
a wonderful campaign we had a nice
series
and there was a medical doctor there who
knew
medical doctors at some of our
university
hospitals
overseas and
it so happened that he
was a speaker
overseas in california
and he ended up there and he told about
the meetings that we had
and so we had an invite
to go and speak at one of our
institutions
and so we ended up in the united states
as a consequence of botswana exactly you
see how yeah everything has a twist and
a turn
and we ended up there
and we found there as always
that there were two camps
those that weren't overly enthused about
what we had to say and those that were
inclined to be enthused
so we had meetings in a hall
and there were
large numbers of people and it's it's
actually quite amazing my poor wife was
still on crutches she was suffering
great pain
because this whole thing wasn't growing
it wasn't growing back so
there was even talk that they might have
to amputate her entire leg
and
at this institution
one of the ladies came to my wife and
said i'm impressed to speak to you
because we didn't say much about what
happened
and what the problem is and her husband
happened to be a specialist
in this particular field
and he
then gave her certain treatments which
were almost miraculous that really
helped her a lot
so god even
arranged that
and we had we had wonderful meetings
and we made many many friends
but the powers that be weren't happy at
that institute
and then one day
we got an invitation
to
come to
the table
shall we say
to the powers that be
and
it was the dean of theology
and a member of the general conference
and it was about preaching to other
denominations
in particular islam
and
there was much anger at some of the
lectures that i'd given on the issue
before
because my my my lectures made it quite
clear
that
what the other religions teach including
what islam teaches
is not in harmony with the three angels
messages or with the bible at all
so we were
blasted
by these gentlemen and told that we must
refrain
from
[Music]
speaking to other religions and trying
to convince them
that they have to come out of her white
people
exactly the same sentiment
as the papers he had right
so the message come out of her my people
was not popular i still thought to
myself and i said to myself you know i i
was an atheist
and i was a roman catholic
and i had to come out of her my people
and join
those that preached the truth right
i had to join the truth
and so i thought to myself hmm very
strange
because they were telling me
that
you leave the people where they are
you don't proselytize
you don't do that
it is not necessary you leave that alone
so i had a little bit of a disagreement
with these gentlemen but they were very
very adamant
so this particular dean who's also very
prominent these days still
preaching a new approach to revelation
chapter 13 as to who the beast is and
who the image of the beast is they have
a totally new theology
redefining
the book of revelation
basically to be in disagreement with the
spirit of prophecy right
said to the law and to the testimony
isn't that important definitely if you
want to preach that
then
why not leave this denomination that you
can become an object of evangelism
correct
so then
after this discussion i
i said to this particular dean
i said to him so
are you telling me
that i
may not preach these things and i get
the feeling that you don't believe
even that the papacy is the antichrist
because i said to him there are many
things that that are
correlating between islam and the papacy
the immaculate conception
their view on on the atonement they
don't believe in the atonement just like
catholicism doesn't believe in the
atonement
and all of those issues
and he said to me you may only preach
what is in the fundamental beliefs
so i said but uh it's very clear that
the papacy is the antichrist and the
fundamental beliefs he said no it's not
one of our fundamental beliefs
i said that's very interesting
anyway i went home and i i made a very
thorough study of the fundamental
beliefs and actually
it was
right on that point in the sense
that it doesn't say we believe that the
paper sees the antichrist
it is it states that the reformers
believed that he was the antichrist
so it implies it but it doesn't say it
so
then i
i so he actually used that as a loophole
he used it as a loophole he distorted it
let's put it that way
but i said to him at the later stage i
said you know
the spirit of prophecy says expose the
wickedness of the man of sin and that's
in the fundamental beliefs that we
believe in the spirit of prophecy so
ipsy facto i must preach it
but if you if you manage to marginalize
make of none effect the testimony
then you can get past that one as well
in any case
francois was with me
and he said this but you know evangelism
brings people into the church
and these messages are bringing or
bringing people into the church because
it clearly states what the difference is
and that you have a choice and people
make a choice
and he said we don't want them in the
church
so i said that's very interesting so he
said he doesn't want that kind of people
in the church he doesn't want these kind
of people that believe that the papacy
is the antichrist etc he doesn't want
them in the church
so we were
absolutely stunned right
and we walked out of there and we looked
at each other
and said
what is this what is this all about and
as we walked out the young man came to
us who had been a new ager
and he said
he greeted us and he said
i was a new ager
and because of your lectures
i have decided to become a seventh-day
adventist
and he was he was so happy and he
embraced us that's the first one we saw
then we went to a meeting from there
and we met a geologist and a
neurosurgeon who had also
accepted the truth and so god
immediately from that situation do not
go and do that stop this preaching
we met three people from all walks of
life
from the highest to
the general public
that
well basically uh
testified to the opposite right
so you have to make a decision what are
you going to do
now interestingly
this sentiment
has become very very prominent
now that was the dean
of
one of our largest
universities
in north america
now many of the theologians
at some of our institutes have that same
sentiment
you don't preach come out of my people
therefore martin you have to redefine
you totally have to redefine 1844
because if 1844
tells you that from then onward a
message went out to the people by a
specific group of people who keep the
commandments of god and hold to the
testimony of jesus
that specific group will bring a message
to every tribe and people and kingdom on
the whole earth and to
every tongue
and that message is the three angels
messages
and one of the three angels messages is
babylon has fallen
and the loud cry is come out of her so
that you have no
part of their sins right
so
that would mean that there is a specific
group at the end of time with a very
specific message from god that has to be
delivered to all the people
that message runs totally counter to
echomenism that's it right it's the
opposite
now as we discussed in our previous
what's up
there are many of our
top
echelons that are
in the economical movement
so they have to stop this message
actually
they have signed that this message has
to be stopped
because there will be no according to
the pope
proselytizing right
and we will not say anything
detrimental about anybody else
and so martin
i came to the to the realization
that there is a new way of thinking
developing
amongst some of our leading theologians
and the first thing that they have to do
is take away the heat
from the papacy
and so they are preaching that the
little horn
might not be the pope
start it gently
that the beast of revelation and the
second beast of revelation are not what
the spirit of prophecy
and the reformers had to say on the
issue
and that the remnant is not a group that
keeps the commandments of god holds to
the testimony of jesus designed to call
a people out of the other institutions
to a
unity with god's word and god's law
but there must be a redefinition of what
the adventist is supposed to be
otherwise we have no identity
so how do you do this
now
i was a speaker at another camp meeting
in south africa
quite an interesting camp meeting
because again
there were two messages
and
there was a group of theologians from
our flagship university in the united
states of america
and they were a group and they were
doing part of the camp meeting and i was
the other speaker so again there were
twin messages that were going on
and basically
they were redefining
our understanding of revelation chapter
13.
now martin
when you start redefining
our understanding of revelation chapter
and you downgrade
those powers such as the papacy
and fallen protestantism
so that
they are not what they
are supposed to be according to the
spirit of prophecy
aren't you then introducing a new
doctrine yes
now
what that dean had told me
that i may not preach that the papacy is
the antichrist it's the same as what
that
representative in germany had told me i
may not preach that the pope is the
antichrist
that is the one thing
uh he also
they also
both of them told me
that
allah was exactly the same god as our
god
and
that kind of teaching
also occurs at one of our large
universities in the united states of
america not only that one
but at another one
so this idea that allah is the same god
as the god of the bible
so as a consequence i decided to study
the quran
and i studied the quran from the back to
the front because that's how you read it
and i discovered
that
the god of the bible and the god of
islam
are definitely not one and the same
this kind of teaching
that changes the purpose of the remnant
from a group that calls people out
to something that glues everything
together
is a totally new concept
now at this camp meeting
they were preaching
that
basically
what we know about revelation has been
totally misunderstood and by the way
that dean just recently also gave a
number of talks where he basically
stated the same thing
so this is not a new thing it has come a
long time
when i studied the quran
i looked at all the points that they had
mentioned
and one of the things is that they they
seem to
lean very heavily on the things we have
in common yeah all right
so what we have in common is the health
message they said
so i read the quran
and the quran says
you may not eat pork right
and you may not
use the normal slaughter mechanisms
they're very same as the bible
that is true
but then when it comes to all the other
things like the unclean animals such as
the camel and everything that creeps and
crawls in the ocean and all of those
things the quran very clearly states
that those prohibitions were simply for
the jews because they were disobedient
but it doesn't apply to them it doesn't
apply to islam
so the
there is no correlation between the
health message of the quran and that of
the bible they are as far removed from
each other as the east is from the west
that's as good as you say that we're on
the same foot as
new ages because they don't eat meat
correct
and then if you take the issue of jesus
they deny the sonship of jesus they say
allah has no son
so all of these issues are absolutely
contrary to the god of the bible then
their doctrine of hell
is
very similar if not worse than that of
the roman catholic system
so there's absolutely nothing that we
have in common
with the quran
even if they thought so in any case when
i was in the south african camp meeting
and our theologians from our
university in the united states were
preaching one message
and i was preaching another message
eventually it came to a private
discussion
and one member of that team came to
the place where we were staying we were
staying in in our camper
and they had a three-hour session
with me
and it was very very
eye-opening
they basically said
that the remnant the seventh-day
adventist is not an organization that
has to call a people out
of babylon
no
we are the glue
that will glue the whole world together
into unity because we have so many
things in common with islam
we have in common
that we don't
eat pork
and with christian the rest of the
christian world we have jesus in common
and with the jews we have the ten
commandments in common
so we have a role of gluing them all
together so the whole role
of adventism has been redefined
has basically been removed as that time
period
when the judgment would commence and i
could certainly understand why it's so
important to them that jesus didn't go
into the holy but went into the most
holy
it sounds to me like
when god called everybody out of babylon
to get the adventist church to go yes
it's like when he dispersed
the languages correct and they tried to
get it back together again now these you
had to come out now they want to get
everybody
together together now it's exact
opposite message
and i thought to myself
this is this is absolutely brilliant
to totally twist the message around from
what it was
to what they wanted to become
button this same lecturer
reposted an article on a facebook page
where it basically states
that i'm a self-proclaimed lecturer
they have basically everything wrong
they made me a professor at cape town
university when i was not a professor at
cape town university i was at the
university of the western cape
but then they said i was a
self-proclaimed lecturer
that i was never employed by the
seventh-day adventist church and that
i'm basically a heretic
now
those statements are quite amazing
in fact
they are libelous
i wonder whether they did a facts check
i was employed by the seventh-day
adventist church as an evangelist for 12
years in two different conferences
and
i'm definitely not a self-proclaimed
lecturer in that field and i'm an
ordained minister in the seventh day
adventist church in good and regular
standing
so
where they come across this information
is
mind-boggling and then the heretic part
that's quite interesting
well if you go back
quite a few what's up profs we showed
that alan white was called the heretic
of the week by the catholic church
so in good company and good company i'm
happy to be in good company and then i
was also told of course
that
i should really refrain from this
freemasonry stuff
because it was not relevant
so they'd redefined the position of the
remnant and and
these are
the organizations
that are supposed to evangelize the
world in a totally new way you don't
call people out you leave them where
they are
you don't tell someone from islam
that he has to come out no he already
has everything all he needs
is to
accept jesus as well and then we're fine
then we're glued together right
and
that night
or that afternoon i had to leave
so we hooked our caravan our camper
and we set off on our journey of about
close to 2 000 kilometers back home
and my wife said to me
you know what
you are inclined to just keep on driving
until you drop
i don't want to do that will you promise
me that when we drive now
when we find a rv park a caravan park
you will go in and you will
please
stop before sunset
and i said sure i'll do that
i'll do that we won't drive through the
night with this thing on the back of the
car
we'll stop
so i said to look up in your
on the internet where these parks are
and in what towns and we'll see how far
we can drive before sunset
so we got away at about two o'clock or
something and i wanted to drive for
about four hours
at least so that we can get a head start
so finally we get to the first town it
wasn't dark yet it was still
around about four-ish
and she says let's look for
the rest camp
so we looked it up on the map drove
there put the gps put it in got there
it was gone
it didn't exist anymore
we asked iran no it hadn't moved it's
it's gone the town doesn't have one
anymore
okay how far is the next time it's about
100 kilometers away let's go
kept on driving
now while we're driving we're talking
about this three-hour discussion that we
had
and we were stunned at what we had heard
and how these people think
and so eventually we get to the next
town there was also supposed to be a
park
it was gone it no longer existed so my
wife was getting a little bit agitated
but what could i do there wasn't one
i said okay let's try and make it to the
next one before complete sunset i think
sunset was around about seven o'clock or
something
we drive the next to the next town some
80 something or 90 kilometers away
the park doesn't exist anymore you know
south africa had gone through so many
changes
and there had been such tumultuous times
and so many bankruptcies and
they just didn't exist anymore and the
towns had had been totally changed
and so
we kept on going
and eventually we couldn't find anything
and by that time
when we got to the final little town
it was already 11 o'clock at night yeah
and
it wasn't my fault i really really tried
to find the place but
it was obviously also my fault
no it wasn't my fault
it was a divine appointment
so
we get to this town
now where is there an rv park in this
town and we get to the entrance and
there's a board up and it says rv park
and it has a telephone number on now
it's 11 o'clock at night
so
i said
let's phone
my wife says you can't phone at this
time of night i said i can i have no
choice i have to i have to go there
so i found this place
and the man answered
and he says yes sure he's got the park
up it's a very small one it only takes
about three
stands it only has about three stands
but there's no one in it you said
come around we'll open up
but he sounded a little bit inebriated
so in any case we arrived there and it
was a hotel
but it also had an rv park
so he opened up this rv park and we went
in and he was flaring his his voice and
he was the manager or the owner of the
hotel and the rv pog
and they'd obviously been sitting in the
bar
having a couple
so we got out
and i said to him i'm going to leave
early in the morning can i pay you ahead
of time
and so i paid him and then he looked at
me and he looked at me in this very
strange way
and he said to me your welter fight
and i said oh how do you know me
he said i watched your dvds
and then he
blasted me
and his tongue was very loose and he was
very angry with me
and he wanted to
pick an argument with me
and then he said to me
i am the grand master of the lodge for
the entire district and he mentioned all
the towns where he was the grand master
and i am a 33 degree freemason
and you are
absolutely off the wall
and his tongue
was loose now he wouldn't normally say
things like that right
and so i said to him yeah well
you have an obvious difference of
opinion on this issue so
i really am tired it's late at night
and i have to drive early tomorrow
morning i'm sorry i i don't have time to
discuss this but he wouldn't let go
so i just started moving away from him
and then he sort of grabbed hold of me
and then he went
ballistic
against jesus
that caught my attention
he
went ballistic jesus is not the son of
god he's not god you christians have it
all wrong
lucifer is the true son of god and he
went on and on and on everything that we
know about freemasonry in any case
but then he said something very
interesting
and we make it our job to prove it to
the entire world
and we have handed out to all the
protestant preachers the quran
because the quran confirms that jesus is
not the son of god neither is he god
that is the truth
so i said you're welcome to your belief
but thank you i'm going to go to bed now
and i
went inside and i closed the door and he
left
i just found it interesting
that the very things that they accused
me of yeah
were confirmed
by this man to the negative right
exactly
he said exactly the opposite of what
they had been saying
and i realized you dare
not
stop
preaching in that
name
and you dare not
stop
saying
come out of her
my people
we dare not allow our
theology to be changed
into one of a collective glue
whereas god says come ye out and be
separate this is an incredibly important
issue
and
if we stick to the bible and the
testimony of jesus christ
then we will understand what the role of
the remnant is
not that we are wonderful
but we are a movement that is to bring a
decided message to humanity
and if we do not unite on the bible and
the spirit of prophecy we will be
divided yes and just because some of
these theologians
are the demons
and the theologians at our largest
colleges and universities
if they start preaching a different
message to what the bible and the spirit
of prophecy and the original
understanding of protestantism is if
they start preaching a message counter
to that
then they are not in harmony with god's
word and just like you that the
disciples did not listen to what the
sanhedrin had to tell them
so
we will not be able to listen when they
say stop preaching these things
this is not a popular message
and you won't be popular for preaching
it no
so martin
if we can stick
to the bible and the spirit of prophecy
we can be a united church and speak out
of one voice
and then we can stand together
against all the accusations and whatever
the world will throw at us correct now
i was uh
much encouraged
after some of our last what's up profs
receive a lot of letters and you
yourself know we
received a lot of letters
and uh
a doctor
who had been trained at
loma lender
uh was very encouraging to talk to him
and he shared some very interesting
ideas with me and one of the things that
he wrote to me
was
this issue of daniel
he said let's read it here he said the
first test that daniel and his friends
went through
was on temperance
and it was basically for the church at
that time
because there were approximately 800
people
that had been taken captive right
and daniel and his friends were the only
ones that stood
for right and said we will not be
defiled by the food from the king's
table
and that was in harmony with scripture
right even solomon said
if you said that the king's table put
your knife to your throat
lest you
succumb to those delicacies right
so the first test was a test
for
god's people yes
and it's a very poor ratio that we see
there
four of them
it's important just to bring it out that
you can read it in the bible and also
the spirit of prophecy especially in
prophets and kings yes it shows this
because maybe a lot of people will not
understand this
but though that 10 days
they were
compared
to their kinsmen
not to the babylonians correct they were
compared to their kinsmen that had come
out in that captivity or that being
taken captive so this first test was on
the health message
and four of them stood for the truth
right so this was a
test within the church and i thought he
made an excellent point there yeah a
test for the church the next test was on
worship yeah so the second test was on
worship and it involved the whole nation
because everybody had to bow down to
that image right
how many did not bow down now daniel
wasn't present he was in another
province at that stage
so only the three friends refused to bow
down
now that's a very poor ratio martin
so all of those that had been taken
captive what did they do they weren't
thrown into the fire
so they bowed down they bowed down and
where did it start
it started with temperance
so the first test is a test on the
health message
the second test will be a test on
worship
now
we spoke a little bit about
cop 26. now cop 26 modern as you know
stands for conference of the parties
conference of the parties that's the
parties that signed
the climate accord
now that took place in 2015
yes
when la data c came out
now next year 2022
will be the seventh year yes since that
signing
in the meantime
of course donald trump had taken the
united states out of the accord
and joe biden had put them back into the
accord
now we discussed what will happen at cop
26 right and the basis for the
discussion according to john kerry
will basically be lodato c right
so i wondered martin can we rephrase cop
26 as conference of the pope
i don't think it's that far-fetched
because all of these leaders including
the spiritual and the world leaders
have gone to him
for
the spiritual
and
their marching orders as to say correct
so they're all first convened at the
vatican and then they go over there and
the pope is
without a doubt the main spokesperson
so
uh i think we can call it the conference
of the pope cop 26.
uh cop could also be an acronym for
close of probation
now
we're being a little bit pushy here
but
should they come to an accord
that it is necessary to shut the world
down one day
in seven in order to save the planet
then we could see the beginning of
interesting things which could lead to a
loud cry which could lead to the clouds
close of probation right
martin is it important
that the debate
as to whether we believe what the
testimonies have to say and whether we
believe that they are in absolute
harmony with the scriptures
that that debate should take place
before the close of probation yes
it might be the most important decision
of
someone's life correct but there will be
voices that say
that preaching what we are preaching
is divisive yes and the papacy has
directly said
that it must be stopped these
evangelists that use the networks to
preach the message right
and this proselytizing must stop
now we've seen that that sentiment has
crawled into the echelons of our own
denomination
and is being propagated by people in
high places
i have personal experience of that i'm
not making this up
now modern
i can't recall that i've changed my tune
over the years
i believe what it says in the great
controversy
it's one thing paying lip service to the
great controversy
and another thing
believing it yeah why is it that when
when lay people take that book and hand
it out in any great numbers there's
always a human cry about it
i don't know because every time when you
hand out that book you get people that
come out of babylon
it is a given it must be handed out like
the leaves of often
if it leads to a shaking
then we will have a people with a
unified voice
so martin what will happen unto this
event which we call the shaking
these truths must be debated
decisions must be made by people whether
they want to run with the come out of my
people theology or whether they want to
run with let's glue ourselves all
together into a collective unit
those are two different gospels
right so let's read a few statements in
the spirit of prophecy and then we'll
wrap this up
truth
present truth for this time
is to be believed and acted upon in
connection with the principles of health
reform
that is exactly what happened to daniel
yep
and daniel was written for our time
the sanitariums which are established
are to be closely and inseparably bound
up with the gospel
the lord has given instruction that the
gospel is to be carried forward
and the gospel includes health reform in
all its phases our work is to enlighten
the world
for it is blind to the movements which
are taking place preparing the way for
the plagues
which god will permit to come upon the
world god's faithful watchmen must give
the warning
those are our marching orders that's it
many will tell us
to desist
many will threaten
and there will be many discussions as to
how to silence this movement
if it is from god
it cannot be stopped
if it is from man
it will lead to nothing
and then comes the shaking
the mighty shaking has commenced and
will go on and all will be shaken out
who are not willing to take a bold and
unyielding stand for the truth
and to sacrifice for god in his course
the angel said
think ye that any will be compelled to
sacrifice
no no it must be a free will offering
any form of compulsion coercion
is not from god
so what is it
that makes us want to preach
the word of god is a fire
and you cannot keep silent
definitely
it will take all to buy the field i
cried to god to spare his people some of
whom were fainting and dying then i saw
that the judgment of the almighty
was speedily coming and i begged of the
angel to speak in his language to the
people
said he all the thunders and lightnings
of mount sinai would not move those who
will not be moved by the plain truths of
the word of god
neither would an angel's message awaken
them
some people are so hardened in their in
their thinking
all the evidence in the world didn't
change them true
and even when god intervened yeah
nothing even if you take the other
quotations that we had from the bible
when peter and them
they even said
they are convicted but they still
beat them
and threw them out
it's amazing
i asked the meaning of the shaking i had
seen and was shown that it would be
caused by the straight testimony called
forth by the counsel of the true witness
to the loudest sins
in other words the true witness to the
laodiceans will tell the church exactly
where
she is not in harmony with the bible and
the spirit of prophecy that's it and
it's not smooth words so it's not words
that fall
soft on the ear no you have to change
and what did what did those people say
when korra and dayton and abayaram
were swallowed up by the ground
it's your fault they thought they would
bring about a new dispensation
none of this you have to do this and you
have to do that
that is thinking exactly like the pope
thinks
this will have its effect upon the heart
of the receiver and will lead him to
exalt the standard and pour forth the
straight truth some will not bear that
straight testimony
they will rise up against it and this is
what will cause a shaking amongst god's
people i believe we are there martin i
think it's culminating and the
the final
act
of this shaking will surely commence
when these laws on sunday and sabbath
are starting started to be implemented
absolutely i never in my wildest dreams
thought that i would ever have to have a
discussion like this one
i always had the hope that it wouldn't
come to this
but it's a vain hope because the bible
and the spirit of prophecy tells me
there will be a shaking i mean
ezekiel is very clear
on the nature of the shaking
and how drastic it will be ezekiel is in
that also telling us of the tweet about
25 that as they backs to the temple and
what what were they doing they were
doing sun worship
now 25 elders it's interesting to me
martin that it says about 25 elders had
their back towards the temple let's not
go into the details of that
but there are some very interesting
thoughts that crop up when you read that
here's another statement from third
testimonies god will not be trifled with
it is in the time of conflict that the
true colors should be flung to the
breeze
it is then that the standard bearers
need to be firm and let their true
position be known
it is then that the skill of every true
soldier for the right is tested shirkers
can never wear the laurels of victory
as we see these things happening
we are admonished to lift up our voices
like a trumpet that's it we cannot be
silent
if it is not in harmony with the bible
in the spirit of prophecy
then we should have nothing to do with
it
and if it is in harmony and we embrace
it then we will speak with one voice
that's it
those who are true and loyal will not
conceal the fact but will put heart and
might into the work and venture their
all in the struggle let the battle turn
as it will
god is a sin hating god and those who
encourage the sinner saying it is well
with thee
god will curse
that's exactly what happened in cora's
rebellion
there were 250 princes
involved in that rebellion men of renown
when we go to the book of daniel
four of them stood for health reform
and they were also princes
coming out of
israel there were 800 of them
and four of them stood out and three
didn't bow down that's an incredible
statistic
colossians 2 verse 8 beware lest any man
spoil you through philosophy and vain
deceit after the tradition of men
after the rudiments of the world and not
after christ for in him dwelleth all the
fullness of the godhead bodily
and ye are complete in him who is the
head of all principality and power
and then from the desire of ases the
church is built upon christ as its
foundation
it is to obey christ as its head it is
not to depend on man or be controlled by
man
many claim that a position of trust in
the church
gives them authority to dictate what
other men shall believe and what they
shall do
they told me that in so many words
they told me what their positions were
and what my task was namely obedience to
their dictates contrary to the bible and
the spirit of prophecy
never
this claim god does not approve the
savior declares all ye are brethren
upon no finite being can we depend for
guidance
may god give us the courage
may god give us the wisdom
to understand his word
it's not enough to have a head knowledge
we have to internalize it you have to
eat the flesh and drink the blood
of the son of god if that
either one of those books
tells you
don't do this or do that then embrace it
and not out of fear not out of fear no
but because you understand the issue and
you want to do it you want to change you
want to be what god wants you to be
i cannot wait for the kingdom of god
and in a sense i'm saddened when i see
these things happen in the church
but i'm also at the point of wanting to
rejoice because i know that the end is
near
and that the suffering on this planet
will finally come to an end i see so
many people
that are cast down
we need to be comforters we need to lift
people up we need to give them hope
but to give them a false hope
is something that god will not tolerate
it's so dangerous
if god
jesus is on his way
to tell somebody no it can maybe be
still for a
for a while
don't do that no let's preach the gospel
irrespective let's pray
heavenly father
the conflict is raging
new ideologies are taking the place of
the old
and there are champions
that want to enforce their new
ideologies
help us to cling
to a thus says the lord in jesus name
amen
thank you for watching this video
to subscribe
click here
when the bell appears click again to get
notifications
to watch the next video
click here
thank you